regardez ce qu'on a avec nous c'est la
nouvelle audi q4 itron sportback
sportback je vous ai présenté l'année
dernière le suv là on est sur la
sportback on a des lignes extrêmement
sport alors on va regarder ce que nous
propose au dc avec cette voiture 100%
électrique on prend la route on est ici
en norvège on n'est pas loin de bergen
on a de la chance il fait à peu près
beau et on y va on part tout de suite
faire un tour de voiture ce n'était pas
mal mais il faut réguler plus d'énergie
c'est un peu mais ça manquait d'énergie
a été un peu mou monsieur je veux de
plus de pêche ouais j'ai envie d'un truc
un peu plus violents viol n'était pas
violent mais à quel prix
ok waouh c'est parti s'ils louent
aujourd'hui autun sa nouvelle audi q4
itron on a le modèle 50 on a presque 300
chevaux sous le capot waouh ça va
déchirer on part on n'y va pas là c'est
toi c'était bien
[Musique]
m
j'arrive je suis juste comme on les
temps est en fait ce soutien a indiqué
pas fonctionnels ils sont chez audi et
je l'avais déjà dit les nanas quand on a
essayé la q4 itron le modèle le suv pas
la sportback c'est que le software je ne
comprends rien ça y est j'ai trouvé donc
là je peux l'éteindre la radio hockey et
il faut se trouver alors je suis
persuadé qu'une fois qu'on l'a pris en
main et qu'on a l'habitude on a tous ses
repères mais quand on n'est pas habitués
qu'on change de voiture différents et
ces compagnies là c'est pas simple et un
truc est vachement bien ici c'est que on
a ce look elle fut sport qu'on n'avait
pas l'année dernière l'année dernière je
devais montrer c'était le plus reste
suivait alors jouera et suivez ici et là
c'est la sportback c'est la sportback ya
des supers link est vachement agressive
regardait les super profits réels et
plus joli et surtout le truc qui est
vraiment die c'est ce que vous allez
retrouver au niveau de l'arrière aucune
la voiture on peut appeler ça comme ça
whaou continue je reste comme ça c'est
bien comme ça ouah
ouah
le truc qui est cool c'est que là où le
suv elle a un peu plus loin comme ça et
tu pouvais mettre une galerie sur le toi
si tu voulais alors et si tu mets pas de
la veille mais par contre c'est tout de
suite ça descende beaucoup plus on va
avoir ce petit aileron là et ça donne
vachement gurls à la team davantage et
c'est vrai que c'est super joli alors
après on va venir trouver ici la petite
partie là quand tu freines tac tac tac
tu le sais et puis un truc hyper canon
ici chez audi c'est toutes les lumières
c'est toutes les petites lettres qu'on
va venir retrouver qui a peint cette
agressivité qui apporte ce look and feel
hypersport à cette voiture c'est par une
voiture de sport mais là le modèle qu'on
a c'est la 50 c'est la quattro en a
quasiment 300 bourrin alors je vais pas
vous parler ici de nombre de choix et
compagnie mais en fait il ya là 35 l'a35
ont un peu tranquille il ya là 40 l'a45
et la 50 45 50 c'est du quatre roues
motrices tac vous avez deux moteurs
différents bah ouais ce que l'éthique
n'est pas la thermique vous avez un gros
moteur à l'arrière et un moteur un peu
plus light moteur à l'avant tandis que
sur les autres et sur la propulsion sur
l'a35 et de l'a47 la propulsion le
moteur est uniquement à l'arrière c'est
ça un peu la différence mais là ce
modèle là là je puis vous assurer qu'en
quatre roues motrices on s'envoie du
noir
ici on est sur la plateforme mb ayez un
truc qui est vachement intéressant est
que nous a mis en avant au 10 et le côté
green alors je suppose que si nous amène
en norvège c'est parce que des jolies
spot c'est joli mais au delà tasser pour
monter le côté un peu écologique parce
que le but en 2030 c'est d'atteindre un
niveau neutre en carbone totalement
neutre alors ça implique pas mal de
choses déjà l'arrêt pour audi de
fabriquer des voitures thermiques alors
ils vont fabriquer je crois c'est
peut-être 2025 elle vous continuent à
vivre pendant quelques bonnes années ils
vont arrêter de sortir de nouveaux
modèles mais ils laisseront vivent les
modèles jusqu'à terminer l'histoire est
finie tout dans quelques années après
mais au-delà de ça il met le focus
vraiment sur la réparation des batteries
déjà ça c'est un très très gros points
et souvent les gens disent on attend
l'électrique c'est cool mais les
batteries ça pollue énormément c'est
vrai donc ils veulent désormais plus
loin ils veulent réparer les batteries
et ça c'est assez marrant et le deuxième
point c'est le recyclage des batteries
sur lequel il travaille pour arriver à
terme à un vrai recyclage des batteries
on n'y est pas mais c'est la volonté de
la marque d'être plus green plus verte
d'emmener les voitures plus loin et
voyez si nous en norvège il ya peut-être
un petit peu ça derrière et en plus de
ça ils utilisent des matériaux recyclés
dans leur voiture ça c'est pas la seule
marque qui le fait c'est souvent les
acteurs de la taille voyez qu'ils
veulent un petit peu se racheter bonne
conscience on disant ah on met des
produits recyclés au mas des mots mais
des matériaux recyclés on va dans le
côté green alors bien évidemment et la
volonté elle est là et c'est chouette on
va pas le contraire mais voyez petit à
petit les choses se font les choses
avancent avec de l'électrique mais déjà
quand on arrivera vraiment à ne plus
avoir d'émission de particules fines et
de tout ce qui va être polluée en bas ça
sera quand même vachement bien même si
on sait que c'est pas parfait et quel
talent derrière
je vous l'avais dit l'année dernière
quand je vous ai présenté cette voiture
là enfin ce n'est pas exactement celle
là mais comme quasiment tout est pareil
ce qui va changer c'est l'esprit
sportback mais tout le reste c'est la
même chose allez jeter un coup d'oeil et
ma vidéo l'année dernière et vous saurez
tout papa exactement tout presse belge
reste sur ce que j'ai dit voyez un an
après j'ai fait d'autres bagnols j'ai
fait pas notre truc et un ans après
qu'est ce que j'ai comme point de vue en
fait c'est que audi c'est vraiment bien
faire des voitures je vous apprends rien
audi est super bon car le véhicule est
génial il se conduit bien le volant est
magnifique on l'a des superbe finition
ils sont un peu en dessous au niveau de
la tête quand marquer alors autant vous
avez tout ce qu'il faut d'un point de
vue logiciel c'est pas forcément simple
de s'y retrouver ça j'en ai déjà dit
mais sinon on a tout ce qu'il faut on
est bien pour la conduite c'est
extrêmement agréable dans les virages ça
roule du feu de dieu ça tombe bien en
plus comme on est sur l'électrique on a
une batterie on est une tenue au sol qui
est magnifique ça bouge pas sa branche
pas je suis en plus sûr du quatre roues
motrices et j'ai pas mis mon gps sous
les yeux ça va être plus compliqué et
comme je suis sur une merde voulez-vous
vous rendre nous happe et lg pas
seulement c'est bon j'ai eu peur comme
je suis sûre du quatre roues motrices ce
à hébron vachement bien donc ça s'est
super bien et c'est vrai que au delà ces
expériences de conduite qui est hyper
agréable sur cette voiture eh bien il ya
toute la notion de teck qui est cool
avec des prises des ports de
rechargement tous les côtés
m
le truc qui est intéressant aussi c'est
le drive select vous allez pouvoir
choisir votre mode de conduite alors
vous appuyez dessus et après vous le
voyez directement efficient comfort auto
dynamic individuel moi j'ai mille
dynamique parce que j'ai un peu de
récupération d'énergie dans ce que je
lève le pied la [ __ ] d'accélération et
web hassan automatique si ça vous
arrange le confort l'efficience ça va
venir consommer un tout petit peu moi ça
va dépendre de votre style ça va
dépendre de ce que vous voulez dans la
conduite des choses ça c'est cool
et là vous avez la conduite à terme
c'est la réalité augmentée voyez votre
destination voyez la vitesse ça vous
indique où est ce que vous allez vous
avez vos différents modes de conduite
enfin truc est quand même vachement cool
et je trouve ça vachement bien parce que
c'est très rassurant lorsque vous
conduisez vous permet d'avoir un plein
d'informations directement sans quitter
la route des yeux
[Musique]
tu es 2
alors le truc qui coule aussi est ce
qu'à fait ici audi c'est à dire qu'ils
ont fait un partenariat avec sonos ces
sonos qu'équipe et du sonos lie à lui
seul sait à quoi il ya dix ans un jeu
croate arias et franchement si vous
voulez que ça bombarde un peu elle est
jouée un peu de musique l'asie mon lapin
quand tu veux
donc là je suis à moitié vrai japan
alors à pousser un peu plus
[Musique]
ça crache extrêmement fort et c'est
truqué coup alors pour autant on va pas
transformer sa bagnole en boîte de nuit
on va pas faire n'importe quoi mais si
vous n'avez pas de club de fermer et que
vous avez envie de vous en continu avec
des copains ou des copines faites comme
vous voulez bien vous avez ce qu'il faut
là et ça c'est bien
[Musique]
mais
tha
un an
les
truc qui est intéressant ici c'est comme
on est sur une voiture qui est hyper
connectés et bien on a tout ce qu'il
faut c'est à dire qu'on à android auto
on à apple car plaît donc si vous voulez
venir connecter votre smartphone android
ou votre smartphone apple votre iphone
pourrait faire très facilement
là vous avez pas de chargement pour
venir recharger votre smartphone sans
fil même remarque que l'année dernière
quand vous avez un très grand iphone et
bien il ne passe pas il ne passe pas à
moi de venir casser le téléphone en tout
cas ça ne marchera pas c'est un iphone
13 promax si vous avez un iphone 13 il
ira très bien et conviendra et bien
évidemment d'autres smartphones android
qui sont compatibles cherchant fils
voilà mais pour celui là regardez on
peut faire ce qu'on veut on peut le
pousser ça ne marche pas au truc
intéressant vous avez deux prises en usb
c'est pour venir vous branchez ici up
l'avenir branché et recharger votre
smartphone filaire parce que si vous
n'avez pas de rechargement sans fil là
ça fonctionnera il y en a une à côté y
en a une de l'autre et vous avez
également du 12 volts si vous voulez
venir vos bronches et ici vous pouvez
faire très facilement et rebelote à
l'arrière vous avez deux prises usb
c'est plus une douce vol pour viande
rouge est ici très facilement
[Musique]
rien en tout cas intéressant ici c'est
que vous avez différentes combinaisons
de feux à led à l'avant alors c'est
marrant vous avez quatre combinaisons de
feux à led 1 2 3 le 4 l'idc
personnaliser la voiture pour avoir je
dirais une gueule un peu différente
alors ça se ressemble un peu c'est un
peu la même chose mais dans le nord ça
peut être assez marrant donc si vous
voulez venir personnaliser l'expérience
un peu autre point qui est assez cool je
pas si vous essayez on en a déjà parlé
fatalement l'année dernière c'est tout
ce qui va être affichage tête haute
alors c'est plutôt bien et j'avais cg
comparé par rapport à une cité sur
l'idée 3 je crois de volkswagen
s'étaient un peu moins évident on le
voyait très très bien mais c'est plus
dur à filmer donc c'est un peu moins
bien là c'est vrai c'est comme l'année
dernière c'est comme ce qu'on a vu ça
vous permet effectivement d'avoir les
informations principales la vitesse vous
avez une caméra qui va venir voir les
panneaux et qui vous met en fait bâtir
le dernier panneau vue c'est ça donc la
vitesse c'est ça vous avez votre vitesse
où il ya quel vitesse vous devez rouler
vous avons plus de grandes flèches vont
vous indiquer la direction vous devez
tourner à droite dé tourner à gauche et
dont toute la navigation qui est là
enfin bref c'est la tête qui est
intéressante et on voit vraiment la
pertinence d'avoir de la réalité
augmentée au delà du côté à gadgets
qu'on peut avoir au travers d'un écran
smartphone là il ya une vraie utilité
sur la conduite on sait pas tout nouveau
attention bien évidemment c'est plus
qu'on a déjà vu on le connaît mais c'est
vrai que en termes de navigation avec
les finitions et le travail que mais ici
ou dit c'est juste magnifique et ça
marche très bien
le truc qui est intéressant que cet
écran c'est qu'en fait on a plein
d'informations c'est intéressant est à
la fois c'est un peu compliqué pourquoi
parce que quand on est en train de
conduire on veut avoir accès à des
informations basiques on veut les
trouver très rapidement et là vous avez
tellement d'informations que lorsque mes
yeux viennent se perdre dessus je sais
même plus ce que je regardais alors je
vois quoi je vois mon niveau je pense
lorsque j'accélère en fonction de mon
niveau de conduite je vois ma batterie
ça je sais pas ce que c'est ce que c'est
la batterie ou pas n'ont pas sûr je vois
ma vitesse je vois la température j'ai
tellement d'informations qu'à la fin je
me perds et ses trucs un peu compliqué
c'est que et regardez même changer la
vue la up ok alors il ya plein de choses
à quoi ça correspond alors quand on
connaît sa voiture probablement on s'y
repère là effectivement j'ai un bout de
gps ok je peux retrouver sur votre écran
un côté on y vient dans quelques
instants mais en fait j'ai plein à fond
et c'est super mais de notre côté on
voit ce que je voudrais c'est une
information simple basique je la veux
clair je la veux lisible et là je trouve
que il y en a trop et que lorsque je
suis en train de conduire je sais pas où
est ce qu'il faut regarder sur les
quelques secondes sur les deux secondes
où les une seconde que je peux venir
consacré à cette partir alors y'a
l'affichage tête haute qui vient un
petit peu corriger ce problème et vous
donner les informations de base mais
pour autant lorsque je regarde ça je
sais pas où il faut aller alors
j'imagine qu'avec le temps aussi repères
mais tout de suite je vous cache pas que
c'est pas hyper et un évident quand on a
un deuxième écran sur le côté alors
celui là est un peu plus tournée vers le
conducteur donc c'est plutôt sympa ce
qui fonctionne bien c'est
qu'effectivement c'est très réactif ça
réagit bien à ça c'est pratique je
trouve que par moments et c'est déjà
leur propre que j'avais fait l'année
dernière on comprend pas forcément
qu'est ce qui se passe au niveau des
menus alors il faut venir gratouiller il
faut venir expérimenter pour comprendre
et à la fin voir un peu ce qui se passe
mais c'est vrai que bon alors après
l'interface est pas mal mais c'est vrai
qu'une fois de plus il faut venir un peu
s'habituer c'est vrai que tesla nous
habituer à voir un truc tellement simple
que lorsqu'on arrive sur toute la partie
utilisateurs à l'expérience utilisateur
ici des fois on se perd un petit peu à
prendre l'a5 petit raconte sur le côté
pourquoi pas ça fonctionne pas trop mal
ce que j'aurais aimé savoir plein écran
un peu plus grand qui descendent un peu
plus bas pour m'apporter une expérience
de collectivités comme on est sur une
voiture connectée une voiture électrique
je voudrais un truc un peu plus
connectée elle l'est pour autant
d'attention elle est vraiment mais je
voudrais que ça envoie un peu plus de
bois au niveau de l'écran un peu plus
grand après effectivement en gros je
retrouve mes petits boutons dessous ça
c'est un truc que tesla fait pas alors
on parle souvent et cela parce que c'est
un peu une des références en termes
d'écrans une connectivité au niveau des
voitures parce que c'est un ordinateur
embarqué mais le gros inconvénient c'est
qu'il faut tout passer par l'écran vous
n'avez pas de bouton eux par contre ici
sont dit on va garder les moutons voyez
que vous avez vos petits boutons pour
votre clé vous pouvez me régler les
choses là dessus que c'est très pratique
c'est très sympa après l'autre pont
aussi je veux un peu reproché c'est que
sur la partie du bal à regarder que vous
avez ici alors vous et votre petit ses
lecteurs pour avancer vous avez le net
vous avez les parkings vous êtes ça
c'est plutôt pas mal mais après alors là
ils m'ont mis un petit commandes pour
venir régler mon multimédia montrent
elles sont accompagnées lors j'ai déjà
sur mon volant enfin c'est plutôt pour
le passager après il ya des boutons très
honnêtement si on n'est pas un
spécialiste je comprends pas je sais pas
ce que c'est que ça par exemple voyez
une fois plus lorsqu'on vient regarder
on finit par comprendre mais je trouve
qu'on en fait et c'est un peu le
reproche de dire faire globalement à ce
véhicule il est super il est complet
mais parfois il est un peu trop complexe
et il manque un peu de visibilité
[Musique]
excès
triêt
[Musique]
ou alors qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de
cette nouvelle audi q4 itron sportback
et bien en fait vous prenez le suv de
l'année dernière vous le sexy fier mode
sport et vous avez cette voiture là qui
arrivait alors pour autant ça fonctionne
super maîtrise de la part de audi super
confort de conduite super pilotage celle
électrique ça du couple ça fonctionne ça
va bien bref c'est très chouette 500 km
d'autonomie on a vraiment un package qui
fonctionnent les poux améliorer c'est
quoi et bien s'améliorer un peu le x
l'expérience utilisateur logiciel que je
trouve ce qui est pas mal mais on peut
encore aller un peu plus loin on a
effectivement tout ce qui va bien
android automne à apple car plaît et on
a dû pas de rechargement même si pour
être un peu plus grands rêves sont là
tout ce qui fait pour avoir une belle
recette une bagnole qui marche très très
bien je trouve qu'il faut améliorer un
peu cette expérience software sinon on a
quelque chose qui marche vraiment bien
superbes lignes superbes véhicules
connectés j'adore je trouve vraiment
très très bien très réussis ça reste
quand même très cher on se parle
d'electric on se parle de voiture
extrêmement cher très près bien mais
pour autant elle truc en train de faire
ici audit c'est de descendre un peu les
tarifs de se rapprocher un peu des
tarifs un peu plus correct un peu plus
convenable même si ça reste quand même
un très gros budget et on sait façon
tout ce qui est technologique et les
voitures c'est la même chose en fait ça
commence tout de suite par le très cher
et ensuite ça descend pour arriver à un
truc plus abordable pour le grand public
alors pour autant je ne suis pas sûr que
cette voiture audi en vente des caisses
mais on voit que c'est le début de la
démocratisation détériore un peu plus
intéressant sur un modèle 35 toutefois
être moi j'aime bien j'ai un vrai
plaisir de conduire avec pour autant
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui j'avais 75 mille
cinquante mille 46000 euros je sais pas
ce que je ferais il ya les modèles de
conduite on voit qu'ils évoluent les
modèles il ya le carsharing 400 je sais
pas en tout cas si vous voulez acheter
une belle voiture électrique si vous
aimez audi pour moi y'a pas photo vous
pouvez y aller peut-être pas sur le
modèle 50 quand même extrêmement cher
mais pourquoi pas une 35 ou une
quarantaine lycée de la propulsion et
que c'est pas du quatre roues motrices
c'est quand même cool dites moi ce que
vous en pensez vous est-ce que c'est des
voitures qui pourrait vous intéresser qu
est ce que vous pensez de la tech
embarquer là dedans ce que ça vous botte
ça vous botte pas à marquer le mois en
commentaire et nous on retrouve très
vite on va continuer à parler de tech
alors pas que l'automobile on en parle
un petit peu quand les opportunités
voyons bien en norvège c'est chouette
mais on parlera de plein d'autres choses
donc je vous embrasse on dévoie très
bientôt le regarde et inspirez vous
respirez la norvège vient à mon coco
regardez comme c'est beau regarder comme
c'est beau la norvège voilà on respire
inspiration expiration
inspiration voilà on est bien on est
heureux souffre et on y va
kiel